[Music]
respect
is something more than aretha franklin
sang about
it's something we're all demanding these
days
but can we ever feel respected until we
can learn
to respect others i sat down with
documentary filmmaker
former u.s ambassador to the bahamas and
philanthropist
nicole avant to discuss the importance
of showing respect this
is a bit of optimism
[Music]
it really is such a pleasure to meet you
i've heard so many wonderful things
about you from some of our mutual
friends
i know i've heard the same and it's it's
about time that we've met
i know i know and i think it's funny
that we're meeting for the first time
like this like on a on a podcast
of course very okay wrong i i won most
talkative in the eighth grade for a
reason
is that a good idea to tell kids what
they're the most of
when they're young like is that it from
now on from the eighth grade that's your
identity you're the most talkative kid
i know it's not very good it's funny my
dad was not happy he said oh that means
you're talking too much in class that
means you're doing this and he took it
very in the negative and my teacher said
no we
we gave it to her because she can
converse with anyone
she converses with the athlete she
converses with the nerds
she talks to the science nerd so in that
way i thought oh i like that i'll take
that
so technically most conversant yes and
it actually gave me
uh when my teacher said that it gave me
a sense of
oh right i can't talk to anybody which
which then gave me a responsibility of
trying to find the common good in people
so it actually turned out to be a good
thing
you know i was very similar i wasn't
sort of in a clique
i was friends i guess if you really had
to force me into one i was probably in
the nerds but i was friends with
everybody i mean my friends in the
theater crowd and i had friends who were
jobs
and that sort of ability to go between
tribes has served me for my entire life
me too
and that's a really beautiful way to put
it which is because we are tribal as
humans
and to be able to navigate through each
tribe
and learn something about someone in
each tribe
helps you break down barriers i think i
mean it served me
for that purpose in my life and how i
moved forward in my life
i always thought oh i understand that
person yeah well i know what that
person's feeling only because
i had played in their sandbox for lack
of a better term of i just went to their
sandbox for a minute and understood
kind of how they behave and what they
think and what they believe and even if
it wasn't really aligned with me or i
didn't have a lot in common
at least i could say oh i've been there
this is interesting
i think that the solutions we find to
the challenges we have when we're kids
become our strengths as adults 100
one of the reason clicks and tribes
exist is they give
those in the tribe a sense of belonging
and psychological safety
um and and it helps give us an identity
right it helps us define who we are
and so what's your identity if you're
not if you're a member of no tribe
because you can understand them and be
with them but you're not really
love them and then you go to the next
one and you can understand with them so
for your ability to go between the
tribes and understand yes it served you
well
and it served you in your career and
your life but then the raises the
interesting question
where do you belong i always knew one
thing that wherever i go
you know because i try to tell my kids
this wherever you go there you are so
you need to
at least like yourself and i remember
thinking for some reason i knew at a
very young age
my purpose was to heal through
inspiration i don't know where i
got that from i don't know if it was me
moving in and out of different
pods or groups of tribes or something
like that i think i created my identity
out of being able to move around so much
and really realizing i can be a
connector of people and that's really
all i saw growing up people always ask
me which what's your
what's my purpose how do i find my
purpose i think everybody's purpose
is to search before we're operating at
our best yes
exactly if we're operating that's the
only deal
i think what's happening with a lot of
younger generations is that they've been
not given the opportunity to develop a
muscle
of resilience and you've got to go
through ups and downs and highs and lows
and you have to
figure out things and start over again
start stop start
stop and learn and when you cuddle
people too much any human being
i'm not judging anybody thank god i mean
i thank my mom now
every day for making me do things that i
was not
comfortable doing making me finish
things that i didn't like you know i
didn't like the violin after five times
my mom said well you've got six more
weeks
and then you don't have to do it again
but you have to finish i couldn't quit
my lessons until i just finished it's a
muscle that i've developed
over time that thank god that has
allowed me to
really look at the reality and give me
perspective
on things you talk about sort of the
over cuddled and much has been written
about this and uh you know
you and i are not the first to talk
about this for sure this generation
of young people who experienced
september 11th
and then went on to have kids and there
was this real
fear for our children for a new parent
uh
in that generation and the theory is you
know became
unbelievably overprotective and is there
an entire generation of kids now growing
up
without the grit necessary to really
thrive
in life and we see we see higher rates
of anxiety and depression
in a younger generation i mean you hear
these stories you know it's one thing
for a parent to call up and say why
didn't my kid get an a
at school we hear these stories of like
25 and 26 year olds of their parents
calling up and saying why didn't my kid
get a promotion
yes and like at some point when do we
let go and allow somebody to scrape
their knees
i was born in 1968 i am the first person
in my lineage in america
that was born with all my rights so it's
a long time
of people not having any right and my
father was born into segregation
born into jim crow had everything
against him
and saw the most atrocious things and
dealt with
um atrocities that no one should
experience i'm just talking about his
experience
this has happened around the world
obviously through centuries
but for me i think what's helped me is
i was so proud of my history whether it
was people in my family
or whether it was people that i read
about whether you know i always
mentioned ruby bridges or ernest green
who was part of the little rock nine
i'm trying to say my parents really gave
me all that
not to scare me and they didn't really
cuddle me but it reminded me
life can be both things it is great and
it is beautiful
and it can be tough and it can be mean
and you do have to scrape your knees and
people
aren't always going to like you and
people aren't going to treat you with
respect
and if you want to be great at something
you have to keep practicing
and someone's always going to out do you
someone's going to practice more
and so i think that by not allowing
a human being regardless of their child
when a human
fall or scrape their knee or be offended
or have something rude said to them it's
very detrimental to the human
soul to not have a tool
to respond your dad is the
personification
of grit yes i mean he came as you said
he came with
everything against him including the law
and then
rose up to be one of the most powerful
music executives in the business at a
time
when there were i mean he was he was the
first of many things he did there were
no
black music executives i mean he he was
it
yes with an eighth grade education which
is astonishing
and was able to give you a life that was
very different than the life he had
very different so you could have been
cuddled
oh yes i could have been cuddled and i
mean yes did i have nice things of
course
but always had a strong work ethic
because i always had to work and i've
done every type of job
like everybody else and i've gotten
fired from a few things i didn't know
what the hell i was doing but i but i
tried and i worked at it
yeah and i for my father it was you know
figure it out that's what my dad would
always say to me
you're wanting this easy path where it's
all smooth
and some roads are paved with rocks or
some roads are paved with pebbles and
some roads are paved with sand
you don't know when i was writing
leaders eat last
i was doing research into parenting and
you know the question is like how do we
become ourselves you know what role do
our parents play
yeah and the research was pretty clear
that
our parents actually are not solely
responsible for who we become you know
our friends and our teachers and our
experiences
they mold us into who we are you know
two parents doing the same thing and a
brother and a sister
turn out completely differently but the
one thing that every child
learns from their parents across
cultures is how to treat yourself and
how to treat others
100 every child gets that from your
parents
100 my friends would laugh at me we'd go
to clubs when we were in college and i
would always clean off the basin
at a club like the worst bathrooms you
could possibly find
and i'd clean my hands and then here i
was pulling down more
uh paper towels and cleaning down the
basin
and my father's looking at what are you
doing and i said well you have to leave
it clean for the next person
and they were looking at yeah but we're
in a club like no one cares someone's
going to vomit
but it doesn't matter but it was a habit
of
look out for the next person you know
holding the door open for somebody i
mean i remember my father
yelling at me over and i was so hurt by
it and i didn't do it on purpose but i
wasn't paying attention and i
i let the door slam on somebody coming
behind us in a restaurant
and you would have thought that i
created the most heinous act but
to my father it was pay attention
there's somebody
coming behind you there is a fellow
human being behind you
pay attention but this goes right back
to the where we started
in high school which is the ability to
go between
groups and be considerate of the fact
that there are different people who look
different and sound different
um and see people for who they are but
it raises the question
again which tribe do you
find safety yeah if you're the one
always thinking about other people
where can you just go
and somebody says it's okay you're
you're one of us we're we got you
like where where is that place for you
where is that place for you
so i definitely am a misfit and
i do well where the misfits go
so i love new york because new york is
the the
island of los toys the island of misfit
toys
you know it's like and i have a test
it's really funny when somebody first
moves to new york you know wherever
they're from
and they're all starry-eyed and like i
made it to new york i have i can ask
them
one question and 100 i'll find out if
they're going to survive or not
and the question is wherever you grew up
you know boise or chicago like wherever
you're from
were you the black sheep you know were
you the ones that people like didn't
really understand
or and they and they would look at me
like no i fit in fine i'm like you're
not gonna last
you're right right but if they go like
you know
yeah i never really fit in where i grew
up you know i grew up in
whatever place and i never felt like i
belonged i always felt like an outsider
i'm like you'll do just fine here
and that's sort of a funny thing so i
love hanging out with artists
they're some of my favorite people you
know and and i love subcultures
um and i find all these little
subcultures where you know a group of
people i like comic-con
you know that that sort of nerdy crew
all the people who are like
laughed at and made fun of because they
like to dress up as superman
not for halloween
and and all of a sudden you're amongst
all the same
weirdo misfits who've been made fun of
their whole life so i'm
good with the other misfits interesting
uh now that you say that i'm i love
living in new york by the way
it was the best time of my life and i
actually talked to
one of my best friends susannah the
other day and i said i was 24
and i felt like i could i was on top of
the world i felt that i was the smartest
at 24. and she said because you had an
unshakable
faith that everything was going to work
out i said i did she goes
unshakable you were in new york like
doesn't matter whatever happens this and
that but it's funny you
you ask that question now that i think
about it it's always with artists
yeah and mostly musicians because that's
my tribe of people that i understand the
most because
we could speak in silence you know i
grew up around musicians
i studied musicians i can sit with them
all day long i understand and even if we
don't say anything
i could sit there for hours and i feel
very safe and i
can let my guard down because musicians
i think and beautiful songwriters are
the most vulnerable
and i learned about life and i still
learn about life more through
music than anything else because there
are beautiful stories that allow my
imagination to see the person
they're talking about to feel the pain
that they're talking about to feel the
heartbreak to feel the joy
to feel the confusion and then what
musicians have always given me is a
sense of not being alone that's that
tribalism
yeah that made me feel oh someone does
know what i'm
feeling i don't want to call it
tribalism because tribalism has
pejorative
connotations that's that's the feeling
of being
in a tribe of finding finding your tribe
yeah yes
so it begs the question then how can
others
find their tribe because a lot of us you
know
sort of go through life feeling
uncomfortable or like we don't belong or
like we don't fit
and that's what every human being wants
it's a basic human
instinct we want to feel like we belong
we want to belong and we want to be seen
we want to be seen and we i mean
basically we want to be respected
seen heard and understood yeah i think
respect is the highest form of love
so everyone's like love your neighbor
it's really for me it's just
give somebody just their basic right of
respect
doesn't mean they're always going to
behave in the same way doesn't mean you
have to like people
doesn't mean any of that but at least
show up with
respect try to and we all fall from that
from time to time but the beauty is
if you have that baseline so to speak
even when you're off and you miss the
mark you'll know it
your spirit will tell you that wasn't
cool you were just so disrespectful
or so rude or uncut and you come right
back and then you're able to start over
because you're able to check your own
spirit this is very interesting i i want
to underscore this
when we are disrespectful we know it and
it immediately went to sort of an
extreme example
that i just learned very recently i i
was talking to dia khan the
documentarian
who made a remarkable documentary called
white right
she is a muslim woman who was trolled by
white supremacists
to the point where the police told her
stay away from open windows it got
really dangerous
wow and what she decided to do was move
to the united states
and spend time trying to get to know
white supremacists and giving the
giving them a safe space to feel heard
which is kind of a remarkable thing
and and she made this documentary where
she she shows it
but the story that's not in the
documentary that i just learned recently
was a number of the white supremacists
through getting to know dia dropped out
of the movement because
they started to trust her and view her
as a friend and one of them dropped out
of the movement after they saw her
documentary
and he called her up and said i'm i'm
leaving
the movement because i saw the movie and
that's not me
and she said did i unfairly represent
you
like did i depict you as you not are is
that what you say that's not me
he says no no you your documentary is
fine
he said i'm looking at myself the way
i'm speaking the way i'm acting that's
not me
that's not who i am so he was shown this
mirror
where he was displaying a lack of
respect where he viewed himself as a
highly respectful and he couldn't
reconcile that
and so the only recourse he could find
was to leave the movement but i find
that so interesting and so
again it's such an interesting point you
make which is we
know like we know when we're when we're
frustrated and short-tempered and we're
rude to the customer service agent on
the other side of the phone
yes we we know yes
some of us have the wherewithal to
apologize in the moment and sometimes we
hang up
and try and pretend that it they should
have done this for me and i'm the
you know but we know we know i think
that's such a fascinating
thing that that that people know when
they're being disrespectful
and you have to we have to be able to
get to the point to self-correct
so how do we do that nicole how do we do
that we live in a world
where the the conversation is how are
you treating me but the conversation is
not
how am i treating others exactly and i
think the focus
you know it's self-idolatry it's
ridiculous everyone's focused on the
self as opposed to looking outward
and we all belong to this one world
there's only one where are we going
anyway everyone's trying to get rid of
everybody where are you going
really where the hell are you going
where do you want everyone to go there's
one world
and i live by the golden rule right at
least that's my intention
right but you are going to err and you
will
you may not do it on purpose but you'll
lose your patience
you'll be short and you'll you're going
to have to reconcile with yourself and
at least
admit to yourself you know what that
wasn't cool
when i was thinking about what i want to
talk to you about you know i wanted to
talk to you about
how you find your tribe i wanted to talk
to you about identity and belonging
because your your story is such an
unusual one and your experiences i
i think very unique and
the more we talk the more i'm learning
what your perspective is
it's magical actually which is i'm
trying to get you to sort of talk about
identity and where you come from and
what your tribe is and what i'm hearing
is that you see yourself as a member of
the tribe called human being
yes and you express concern at this new
exaggerated it's not new but it's
definitely exaggerated in our time
us and them right and wrong and it leads
to this
terrible self-righteousness and this is
what i think the
the sides miss which is both sides think
they are
right the self-righteousness is
the problem i heard somebody say it's
really great he said
um he has to remind himself sometimes he
says i look at the mirror and i say to
myself
there is a throne there's somebody on it
and it's not
you you know and i i look at that
and i think we're all attacking each
other because everyone to your point
thinks that
they're right and their belief is the
only belief
their way is the only way and what that
says to other people is
your opinion doesn't matter your
feelings don't matter
you don't matter respecting you doesn't
matter
um honoring your soul doesn't matter
and those are all lies we've seen
throughout the beginning of time
that societies do well when
they're and that's what i think the
beauty of america is with all of its
faults and everything else the reason
we're
still the the beacon to everybody is at
least self-correct
at least you turn around and you make
things right and it takes a lot and i
think
this generation doesn't realize things
take
time oh that's that's that thing that
your friend said about you which is you
know you have this undying belief that
everything will work out and this
you just glow with optimism but i want
to know what the first step
is i agree with you i think it can and
will work out but
when a group of people storm the capital
and believe that they are right the next
day the self-righteousness
or somebody who uh spits on
a racist you know at a rally
the self-righteousness in that too that
i feel that i i did right
you know i i yelled at that person and
and and i go home and feel good about
myself
but it did very little to anything i'll
even go so far as to say nothing
to move the needle solve the problem or
bring humanity back together
yeah because it's never okay again going
back to that basic golden rule it's
never okay
ever to disrespect another soul
on purpose yeah we do it all the time
but not on purpose to hurt someone
physically
emotionally spiritually is
never okay so nicole avant what's the
first step
i think the first step is you have to
see the other person as
yourself how how do you do it i i
honestly look at everybody like this is
a human being who has the basic human
rights the same exact human rights
and the same 24 hours every day that i
do we are the same
we belong to the same tribe we belong to
the same race which is called the human
race that's where i start because we
live in a world right now where we're
starting to see each other as lesser
i know that that one group of people is
undeserving of dot dot dot
right and it's not true and it is a lie
you have to stand on truth we're all
stay everyone's standing on quicksand
you have to stand on concrete it is not
true though would you everyone says i i
was i was right i could spit in that
person's face i could spit in that cop's
face i could spit in that racist face
really is it okay if they spit in your
face
i don't think so but really but let me
play devil's advocate right
yes but they've been oppressing me for
years that it doesn't matter what
they've been doing because an eye for an
eye lose everyone blind
we all know that too again the idea of
being so self-righteous
to say well they hurt me so i can hurt
them
well they did this so i can do this no
you've just become that person so what's
the difference
you're the same yeah now you've become
them
and i think your example was great that
man who dropped out of the white
supremacist group
he didn't want to identify as that
person
i think for me what do i want to
identify as what type of human being
do i want to be to my fellow man
i i asked dia how she got the courage to
go
spend time with white supremacists and
give them a safe space to speak
you know to empty their bucket as she
calls it and
she said leading up to that moment it
was all about them
trying to convert them and convince them
and put them down you know and she went
to the rallies and yelled at people
and had that sense of self-righteousness
and she realized that she was
accomplishing nothing
except making herself feel better about
herself right and
she she said it was it was nothing about
them it became about her
which is she didn't go to see them to
convert them or change them or convince
them they were wrong
she went to see them because she it's
the kind of person she wanted to be
she realized that she wanted to be the
person who was capable of listening
and holding space and not trying to
convince them that they needed to be the
kind of people
to listen and hold space right i think
i've learned in my life and i'm sure you
have the more i listen
and i just let people go even if i
disagree with them completely
all right just let me hear you out just
you know
my dad was very good at that let me just
hear it out
and you might get one kernel of
something but the more and more
people start to become more and more
vulnerable
and and then a solution
usually comes out without you having to
do anything the person
changes on their own to your point this
man what's so interesting
what you're pointing to is that what we
are doing
is curating our own echo chambers where
we're making our own cnns and our own
fox news
where we are literally excluding people
from our friend group
who disagree with us or
don't share our exact point of view so
the only people we're surrounding
ourselves with are people reinforce
sometimes our worst tendencies and
and the question is how do you be
friends with someone that you could like
i have one friend in particular that i'm
thinking of
who she and i are on opposite sides of
the political spectrum
and we have very different opinions of
how the world works and should work
and i remember once we were walking
somewhere and we were
one of us brought something up and
she started to explain some of her
points of view
and i think i actually said the word i
definitely thought it but i think i
actually said how can you be so stupid
and she stopped and she didn't attack me
for my argument she attacked me for
calling her stupid
and i realized i just called my friend
stupid and completely
dismissed any opinion or point of view
she has
and i i took the first step to
destroying a friendship
because i loved her and she was good to
me and kind
you know and we realized that we could
piss each other off when we didn't
listen to each other and so i
learned from that friendship instead of
dismissing and walking away from the
friendship
i had to learn to
ask her questions with curiosity as to
how
she came to her point of view and why
that point of view matters to her
with genuine desire to understand and
what i learned was though we still
disagree on many things
we're always able to find a kernel
that we can agree on exactly and find
common ground
when we find that kernel we become very
interested in the other person's point
of view
to teach us not to convert the other
because if you think about it
when we surround ourselves with only
those who agree with us we create our
own echo chambers
right and that goes for almost
everything we follow the people we agree
with we watch the shows we agree with we
listen to podcasts we agree with right
and if that person says one thing we
disagree with
we unfollow right like i've actually had
it happen where i posted something on
instagram
and somebody wrote in the comments i've
loved your work for years i've read all
your books but i completely disagree
with this
i'm unfollowing you yeah when we
surround ourselves only with people who
agree with us we become
so sensitive to anything that is
dissonant
right where when we learn the skill
to include accept respect i love your
your your word respect what we actually
do
is we become better friends my dad now
if i go to his house if i go to my
parents house
he's flipping channels you know i gotta
watch cnn then i gotta watch fox and i
have to watch what everyone's saying
you have to listen and he will and he
gave me that which is you gotta listen
to what everyone's saying
you want to be able to say hmm i didn't
think about it that way
i never thought about that oh i
understand that you know
try and listen even if it's polar
opposite you know i think that was again
going back to the civil rights movement
and exactly what dr king did you know i
always say he was one of the best
strategists
i have ever ever been inspired by
he this whole idea of everyone thinks oh
non-violence oh which is love everybody
this was strategic
thought out process and
sending people to meet gandhi in india
so that they knew
bring this back we need that teaching
here this is going to be the ark this
non-violent movement that gandhi started
we can
now take that and bring it to black
americans here
and use that that was the driving force
do we think that dr king agreed with
everybody he tried to make deals with
all the time
obviously not do you think that him and
lbj just stopped there all the time and
oh yeah sure
no and yet they're there they're next to
each other it's back and forth and up
and down and around and about and you
know what but the results
we got it and to underscore the movement
the movement was bigger than the people
and the movements take
time movements take time
every single founding member of the
women's suffrage movement
had died before the first woman voted
i tell everybody i stand
on very brave strong courageous
shoulders now i'm sitting here on this
podcast with you
because there were people that
didn't quit because they knew that they
were planting seeds
and that one day something would sprout
and they will have
all these things that they are fighting
for and that sprout is me
and that's why i don't take my life for
granted i'm one step removed
from people that literally didn't have
any
rights at all and it takes time
my grandmother her mother her mother her
mother goes
all the way back and beatings and
lynchings
imagine living a life like this of not
looking up she said oh some days
i just walked home from work you know
which was god knows how many miles
because i didn't want to look up because
i didn't want to see
anybody that i knew hanging from a tree
and i thought what but
that was her reality at that time
and she never gave up she went to try
and vote
god knows how many times turned away
each time
laughed at each time spit on each time
and now for me that's why i look at
people like you have no right not to get
up and vote are you kidding me
it doesn't matter if you believe in this
get up and go and
vote for the simple
reason of just somebody actually
literally died for you to have this
right
and freedom is not free and freedom
takes time and laws take time
and work work it's like it's like any
relationship right you talk to the best
marriages
and you say what's your secret they say
it's it's a lot of work
it's a lot of work and all of this stuff
that we're talking about called humanity
and society and freedom all of these
things are not
prizes to be won they're relationships
to be managed
they all require huge amounts of work
all the time
you said the perfect point which is our
whole reason of being on this earth is
about human relationships
everyone has a relationship with each
other
and it's imperfect and messy
and human because life is messy and life
is beautiful it's always an
end you know and and and there's good
there's bad there's ugly there's
happiness there's sadness
it's all together but
that's what it is and there are
mountains and there are valleys and i'm
telling you the only time that my
character has ever been tested as yours
or anybody else's it's not on top of the
mountain
for christ's sake it's always in the
valley it's always in the weeds
and in the weeds is where you grow and
in the weeds is where you learn and in
the weeds is where you get hurt
and in the weeds is where you hurt
somebody and you learn or hopefully
and you grow and then when you get to
the mountaintop then that's the time to
pull people up
and that's the time to turn around and
look who else is climbing up the
mountain
and try to bring them along and i think
it's the human
process of life here's what i've learned
from you today
which is to think about human society
like recycling
which is you know when you take
something and you put it in the garbage
and we literally say
i'm going to throw this away where
exactly is
away it's like blowing the leaves from
your yard onto your neighbor's yard
look i've gotten rid of the leaves right
and that's what we do with garbage i
move it from here
to there but it's still on the planet it
hasn't gone anywhere
right right we've just removed it from
my site
is basically where we remove this
garbage from my site is actually more
accurate
right and this is the same with people
you and you said it which is where
exactly do you want them to go we want
to get rid of all of these people
where exactly are they going to go yeah
you know which is it's all on the planet
yeah the thing we have to do is learn to
be with each other learn to take care of
each other learn to use
the talents and skills that each other
have and it's not all pretty
and it's not about changing them and
converting
them it's about who do we want to be
what kind of person do
i want to be and we're all so busy
trying to
hold on to our tribe and compare the
value of
my tribe to the value of your tribe and
my tribe is more valuable than you're a
tribe
and to your point we're all a member of
one tribe called the human race and we
better take care of our tribe
because otherwise we all live otherwise
we all lose
nicole i am proud to be in your tribe
with you thank you i'm so happy to be in
your tribe thank you so much
so great if you enjoyed this podcast and
you'd like to hear more
please subscribe wherever you like to
listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other
you